- Please say a big hello
there to Tabitha Brown.
(applause)
I can't believe you're here.
I'm geeking out!
- My goodness.
I'm so excited.
I can't believe I'm here.
- All right, Tabitha. What are we cooking?
- You ready to eat?
- [Drew] I am ready to eat.
I don't know why, but my hips are moving.
I don't know what that's about, but.
- You know, we dance when we hungry,
and we know it's going to be good,
and we dance sometimes. That's how it be.
- It's true. And the
grilled cheese is truly one
of my very favorite
things on planet earth.
So I'm really, really excited.
- I love a good grilled cheese.
And you know, when I want to
make myself feel like I'm doing something
a little fancy, I add my
spinach and my garlic.
Shall we make one?
- Yes. And I think your approach
to this honestly, is
something I've never seen.
So teach us, Tabitha,
teach us your brilliance.
- Here we go--okay. So first real simple.
We take our wheat bread, right?
One slice. Let's get a
little bit of butter.
Okay.
We're gonna put our butter on the bread.
And we do this for two reasons.
One, so we can have it like,
nice brown toasted look.
- Mhm.
- But also, the cheese and the spinach
sticks on to the butter.
Okay? Because we're going
to put it on the outside.
- So the butter kind
of acts as an adhesive.
- Yeah. It's like the glue.
This is the outside of the bread.
So don't put too much.
This is the outside.
- Oh, did I overdo it?
I do that in the kitchen.
I overdo it.
I have no art of subtlety in the kitchen.
- Put a little bit of
garlic powder on the bread.
Like, so like that.
- See, I would never think to do this.
- Cool, girl. Okay, so then--go ahead.
And we put it face down with all
your coverings in your skillet.
Okay. Do that. Then while--
- It's sizzling!
- [Tabitha] Yeah. And then
go ahead and add your cheese.
All right.
- And this is vegan cheese.
- [Tabitha] Yeah.
All right. Now go ahead and
put your other one on top.
All right.
And we'll get ready to flip it.
Flip it.
Cheese melts quick.
(audience cheers)
- I love it.
I have such a, like, support team here.
This is so cool.
What do you say?
Don't go ruin nobody's day now?
Can you say it for me?
- You have to say, have
yourself a good day,
but even if you can't have a good one,
don't go messing up nobody
else's. That's how my--
(applause)
My daddy always told me that.
He still tells me that
today, he always says that.
So I have one that is already finished.
Do you?
Cause this one, the cheese is melted,
but I want you to just--
- I, I think mine is good.
Now, how do you like to cut your bread,
or do you leave it whole?
- Oh girl. No, you know we gotta,
we have to cut and you know,
like a little triangle.
Make us feel like a kid again sometimes.
- [Drew] This is stunning by the way.
(applause)
Okay. Tabitha, how did I do?
- Oh, you did amazing, girl.
Look at you, showing off in the kitchen.
(laughs)
This is when you dance,
cause you did it, yeah.
(laughs) Come on, girl.
Yeah, girl. That's what we do. So, yeah.
- Can I taste it now?
(claps)
- Girl, that is the best part.
Oh God, we thank you.
Yes, we're gonna taste it.
Amen to that.
Ready? Mm.
(applause)
(laughs)
- That garlic powder is so extraordinary.
It's such a unique flavor
and goes so well with it.
I would have never thought to have--
I might just have to take another bite.
- That's your business.
You take two bites.
- Oh my god. Tabitha, thank you so much
for changing my perspective
on the grilled cheese as well as life.
Thank you Tabitha.
(applause)
I can't help it.
I love you.
I would love to hang out with you again.
- Girl, we'll get together.
I love you back. (laughs)
- I need you, Tabitha.
Thank you so much for being here.
(upbeat music)